falls ihr Folge 1 und 2 verpasst habt
schaut ihr am besten zuerst ich habe mir
die Monopoly Reise Edition gekauft um
das Spiel in Reallife zu spielen
gestartet bin ich mit einer Reise an die
Küste von Lagos in Portugal ein wirklich
toller Ort am Atlantik der jedes Jahr
viele Urlauber lockt weiter ging es mit
dem günstigsten naflug in die spanische
Mittelmeerstadt Valencia dort befinde
ich mich auch aktuell noch und möchte
nun schauen wo meine weitere Reise
hingeht viel Spaß mit der dritten Folge
von Monopoly travel Edition in real life
und damit ey Leute was geht ab herzlich
willkommen zu einem Video ich hoffe
natürlich euch geht's gut mir auch ich
bin jetzt mittlerweile zwei Tage
unterwegs
und wir sind jetzt gerade falls ihr euch
erinnern könnt schaut auf jeden Fall
sonst erst erstmal Videos Episode ein
warum sind hier so viele Fliegen Episode
1 und Episode 2 auf jeden Fall befinde
ich mich immer noch in einem Park mitten
in Valencia in Spanien und wir holen
jetzt Monopoly raus und würfeln erneut
weil ich möchte wissen wo es hingeht und
im besten Falle möchte ich heute noch in
ein anderes Land okay Leute ich habe
alles aufgebaut wenn ihr jetzt verlangt
fragt er sich auch wahrscheinlich was
macht der Typ da warum hat der monopolis
vor allem der hat ja nicht mal
Gegenspieler gestartet haben wir mit der
Küste von Lagos da ging es weiter zum
nachflug das war der günstigste Flug
nach Valencia okay Leute
dann würde ich sagen wir starten drei
zwei
acht das weiß auch nicht
wiederholen
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
was war das Reisetagebuch Karte ich
hatte lieber so eine Karte ich glaube
die sind interessanter wir schauen mal
rein dein Reiseblog hat tausend Follower
Reise weiter und schieße Fotos Stempel
diese Karte ab ja toll Smiley jetzt habt
ihr eigentlich nicht mal einen Reiseblog
okay Leute meine Idee ist folgendes ich
habe natürlich Instagram und dann nehme
ich die Leute die mir davon auch mal so
ein bisschen mit also die wissen
eigentlich schon immer ein bisschen eher
wo ich so Lande als die Leute die mir
nur auf Youtube Folgen deswegen kann ich
euch eigentlich nur empfehlen die mir
mal bei Instagram rein zu folgen Alex
wie heiße ich da und ich mache jetzt
einfach folgendes ich frag bei meiner
Story wie soll ich als nächstes
weiterreisen wo soll ich hinreisen
vielleicht gibt's ja irgendwie in der
sicher gut auskennt mit Sicherheit und
ich kriege ein paar coole Tipps und eine
Sache wenn ich dann davon machen also
ich bin mal gespannt was sie mir da so
schreibt also ich habe auf meinem ganz
persönlichen Reiseblog jetzt mal das
gepostet oder ich werde jetzt posten ich
bin in Valencia Spain bin ja gerade in
Valencia irgendwelche Vorschläge und
Tipps wie und wohin ich von hier aus
weiter soll wie wollen sie euch
weiterreisen kann mir jeder schreiben
und dann werde ich mir da irgendwie was
raussuchen und draußen das ist doch
eigentlich oder was Besseres hätte ich
mit der Karte jetzt nicht machen können
ich bin mal gespannt sehr viele von euch
ziemlich plötzlich immer ein dass ich
doch mal versuchen soll mit dem Boot
weiterzufahren ich bin ja hier am Wasser
valencia hat z.B auch ein Hafen ich weiß
es nicht ob der besonders groß ist aber
der ist 3 km von hier entfernt ich werde
jetzt mal hin latschen und schauen ob
ich von da aus irgendein Boot bekomme
irgendwohin es ist womöglich von dort
aus nach Gibraltar zu fahren einziges
Problem also Gibraltar kennt man ja
diese mehr Engel ne einziges Problem von
da komme ich eigentlich gerade also Faro
ist auch nicht weit von Gibraltar
entfernt und deswegen finde ich das ein
bisschen suboptimal ich muss aber sagen
jetzt die nächste Etappe mit dem Boot
einfach irgendwohin zu fahren finde ich
ganz gut weil ist natürlich auch ein
bisschen klimafreundlicher dann fliege
ich nicht wieder direkt und ja auf Boot
fahren hätte ich auch Lust so schön zum
Sonnenuntergang wir schauen mal
vielleicht kann ich da ja was Leute kurz
als Info hier seht ihr einmal den Hafen
von Valencia von oben ich habe mich noch
ein bisschen rum gefragt und mir wurde
gesagt vom nachbarhafen den ja fand
deutlich mehr touristische Bote also bin
ich dann mit dem Taxi weil ich keinen
Zug mehr bekommen habe darüber gefahren
und von da aus geht's weiter
okay Leute ich habe es zum Hafen
geschafft der ist da da vorne ist es
glaube ich das tourismusgebäude wo ich
rein muss hier sehe ich jetzt gerade zum
ersten Mal das Mittelmeer aber das war
jetzt so anstrengend wir haben gerade
aktuell 34 Grad auf meiner Wetter App
und die Sonne knallt immer noch total
von oben ich bin dann um 16:55 Uhr im
touristischen Hafengebäude angekommen so
sieht das da aus und auf der
Anzeigetafel stand noch eine Fähre nach
Palma über Ibiza soweit ich weiß
allerdings hätte ich die nicht mehr
erwischt das habe ich gar nicht
hoffentlich fahren danach auch noch
welche Leute die Fähre die ihr da drauf
fahren seht die fährt jetzt nach Malle
und dann nach Ibiza nee andersrum die
habe ich aber leider nicht
[Musik]
ich trinke jetzt kurz beim Wasser hier
aus und dann frage ich mal nach wo ich
dann heute noch hinfahren kann sorry
Englisch okay
die Leute die mich schon seit keine
Ahnung fünf sechs sieben Jahre so
verfolgen haben das vielleicht schon mal
auf insta oder so gesehen aber ich war
in meinem Leben schon 24 mal auf
Formentera weil meine Eltern halt sehr
oft dahin fahren und ich bin mir aber zu
1000% sicher dass es eigentlich vom
Festland hier nie direkte Ferien gehabt
man muss immer erst nach Ibiza und
konnte dann von Ibiza rüber fahren oder
einmal am Tag fährt glaube ich auch eine
von Malle weil die Insel ist Arsch klein
deswegen wunder ich mich jetzt dass ich
von hier aus dahin fahren kann oneway
anscheinend 2 Stunden 30 und ihr habt ja
mitbekommen dass wir heute die letzte
Fähre sonst muss ich bis morgen warten
dann könnte ich auch andere Ziele
ansteuern und die Frage ist jetzt
natürlich wie ich weiter fort fahre das
Ding ist ich kenne die Insel wirklich
hin und nicht ich glaube die 27 km lang
ich war dort überall schon ich habe
alles in meinem Kopf eigentlich
abgespeichert keine theoretisch jetzt
dahin fahren dort nach bleiben Probleme
Kommentare wird von Jahr zu Jahr teurer
es soll so eine Luxus Insel werden ist
es natürlich auch schon und die Hotels
sind wirklich Arsch teuer vor allem wenn
man kurzzeitig Bucht aber eine Nacht und
dann könnte ich morgen nach Ibiza fahren
und dann eventuell die Reise
weitermachen irgendwann das ich glaube
das mache ich jetzt einfach so ich will
mein Ticket kostet 75 € und dann geht's
hier auf die Tiere und mal schauen wie
die aussieht weil ich kann eigentlich
auch die Fähren alle auswendig die muss
anscheinend neu sein und eine Sache die
mir jetzt auch mal so langsam klar wird
es muss doch einfach unfassbar geil sein
so wenn du irgendwie 18 19 20 meint
wegen auch 30 bist und hier vom Fest
dann kommst es ist nicht so wie bei uns
in Deutschland wenn ich zum Beispiel
jetzt mal feiern gehen will am
Wochenende dann fahre ich vielleicht mal
nach Düsseldorf oder Köln und hier die
Leute setzen sich einfach aufs Schiff
und fahren zwei Stunden nach Ibiza das
fehlt in Deutschland okay ich bin drin
das Ding ist aber hier am fest dran es
spricht niemand Englisch wirklich also
das wusste ich gar nicht also für so ein
Land wie Spanien klar in den
Urlaubszielen das Sprechen alle englisch
aber hier irgendwie fast keiner ich
sitze im Boot Leute so sieht das hier
aus
ich wusste echt nicht der Song großes
Brot noch Kommentare fährt immerhin reif
für mich Leute eine Frage ihr müsst mir
in den Kommentaren helfen wer ist dieser
Typ vielleicht irgendein spanischer
Schauspieler oder so keine Ahnung so
viele Leute mit dem Foto gemacht
deswegen lustig dass er bei mir ins Bild
gelaufen ist schreibst du in die
Kommentare
[Musik]
okay Leute nach zweieinhalb Stunden
angekommen geil und genau hier bin ich
wirklich schon keine Ahnung wie viel mal
lange steppt früher habe ich sogar mal
hier geangelt da vorne aber das nicht
mehr erlaubt übrigens die Insel ist doch
nur 19 km lang ist damit aber auch die
kleinste Baleareninsel neben Menorca
Mallorca und Ibiza Kommentare hat keinen
eigenen Flughafen ist aber bekannt für
diese wirklich traumhaften Strände und
deswegen fahren super viele Leute mit
den Booten von Ibiza oder Mallorca auch
mal rüber um dort den Tag oder auch
mehrere Tage zu verbringen und der
livestreet auf der Insel ist in den
letzten 20 Jahren 30 wirklich enorm
gestiegen aber ich zeige euch gleich
natürlich noch ein bisschen was kleines
Update ich bin auf jeden Fall gut
angekommen ich habe mir jetzt so eine
Art Airbnb ziemlich direkt am Hafen
geholt und was ich dazu sagen muss also
ich habe gestern jetzt gar nichts mehr
gefilmt wir haben jetzt heute schon den
nächsten Tag ich werde aber erst morgen
wieder abchecken also ich habe jetzt
muss ich sagen auch diese zwei Tage so
ein bisschen leicht ich will nicht sagen
zu Erholung ich sag einfach mal als
Zwischenstopp und ich dachte mir kommen
wenn ich jetzt Lande dann mache ich das
auch einfach weil es einfach eine
richtig geile Insel und wenn ich es gut
verbinden kann hier mit warum nicht aber
dann führen wir das Projekt auf jeden
Fall intensiv und stabil weiter nicht
solari Fari mäßig Alex du darfst dich
nicht zu sehr entspannen weil es muss
geil weitergehen ich denke heute Abend
werde ich dann das Spiel rausholen und
wir würfeln und dann geht's morgen
wieder von der Insel Weg es geht nach
Ibiza dort ist ein Flughafen und ich
weiß nicht wahrscheinlich wird oneway
schwierig weil obwohl an sich würde ich
gar keine Spekulation aufstellen ich bin
gespannt wo es weiterhin geht und dann
sehen wir uns später wieder ich habe
mich spontana noch ein Auto gemietet um
möglichst schnell an viele Spots die ich
euch einmal zeigen wollte zu kommen ich
hatte halt auch nur diesen einen Tag so
gesehen der Norden der Insel ist
mittlerweile extrem überlaufen da sind
auch diese ganzen Traumstrände weiter im
Süden gibt es allerdings auch noch
Strände wo viel weniger los ist manchmal
ist man da sogar alleine erster Stopp
für mich war kappte Barbaria da war ich
nämlich schon übelst lange nicht mehr
dort befindet sich auf jeden Fall ein
alter Leuchtturm und ziemlich hohe
Klippen
bis da unten hin ist mir jetzt echt zu
weit
sind noch 1,5 Kilometer
habe ich mich auf den Weg gemacht zum
piratus und da was zu trinken das ist
eine ziemlich coole Bar liegt direkt am
medianstrand Ecke arenalstrand schreibt
sich also auf wenn ihr mal auf
Kommentare sein solltet da sind auch
immer sehr viele Deutsche kann ich schon
empfehlen also es ist immer ganz
entspannt der Besitzer ist in
Deutschland da kann man auch gut zum
Sonnenuntergang oder aber noch immer mal
ein paar Bierchen schlürfen so abends
immer ziemlich voll
und von dort aus habe ich mich auf den
Weg gemacht zusammen Naturstrand wo
wirklich nicht viel los ist
[Musik]
ich bin hier übrigens gerade an einem
der letzten Naturstrände von der Insel
natürlich ist es ein bisschen doof mit
dem ganzen See Gras hier aber sonst ist
passiert
eigentlich der einzige vorne liegen zwei
drei aber ja wie man sehen kann alles
frei die Sonne geht gleich auch schon
unter wir haben schon wieder 19:30 Uhr
oder so die Tage vergehen so schnell ich
weiß nicht warum es so ist obwohl ich
nur alleine bin und eigentlich kaum
Person hat mir nicht kommuniziere da
geht die Zeit durch diese ganzen vielen
Eindrücke in kurzer Zeit trotzdem sehr
sehr schnell und das ist doch auch
einfach ein geiles Bild ich habe noch
ein Bier dabei
der letzten Zopf an dem Tag habe ich in
der Blue Bar eingelegt eine coole Bar
mit auch einem schickeren Restaurant wo
man wirklich sehr sehr lecker essen kann
und abends sind dann auch immer so
kleine Partys wo Bands auftreten dort
ist es ein bisschen teurer aber es geht
noch fit also es gibt auch deutlich
teurere Läden dort noch das werden auf
jeden Fall ein paar meiner Empfehlung
[Musik]
[Applaus]
okay Leute die letzten beiden Tage war
jetzt ein bisschen kuddelmull ich habe
einiges mit dem Handy mitgefilmt habt
ihr sicherlich alles gesehen aktuell bin
ich immer noch auf Formentera wir haben
jetzt heute Sonntag und jetzt geht's
aber mit der Fähre später rüber nach
Ibiza und dann von dort aus irgendwie
weiter wo es hingeht weiß ich noch nicht
deswegen werden wir es jetzt mal
ermitteln ich bin gespannt und ich hoffe
es wird geil ich musste mittlerweile
auch dringend mal meine Sachen waschen
naja
hier haben wir die Spielkarten
Spielfigur bin so dumm ich habe meine
Laptop einfach in den Rucksack gepackt
ich habe auch einfach erst nach drei
Wochen gemerkt dass dieser Rucksack noch
dieses Laptop hat naja okay Leute ich
befinde mich hier auf Reisetagebuch und
hier kommen jetzt einige wirklich sehr
sehr nice Sachen wir sind übrigens fast
schon wieder am Anfang Leute hier habe
ich ja angefangen schon einmal fast ganz
rum
oh eine drei schon wieder so eine
scheißkarte 1 2 3 das ist jetzt Ereignis
Feld das sind diese Karten du machst ein
Foto von irgendetwas
nein Porsche okay Alter Loch Ness
ich muss wirklich sagen ich war früher
absolut fasziniert von Loch Ness ich
habe mir so viele Dokus reingezogen weil
ich habe immer dran geglaubt da gibt es
ein Monster und dass ich da irgendwann
mal Hinreise gerade für Youtube Videos
hätte ich niemals gedacht und das
scheint als ginge es wirklich zu Loch
Nessi heißt ja das Monster viele sagen
es existiert viele Taucher waren schon
im See haben es noch nicht gefunden es
gibt ganz viele Verschwörungstheorien
also Bums deswegen bin ich mal gespannt
da geht's auf jeden Fall als nächstes
hin warte mal ich überlege gerade wie
viel Grad haben wir denn da das so ein
Schottland 15 Grad
scheiße und wir haben jetzt gerade
mitten am Nachmittag da ist es einfach
morgens 9 Grad ich habe gar keine langen
Sachen mit Ausland Pulli das viel zu
kalt das mache ich jetzt okay ich muss
mich mal sammeln Flüge buchen ich weiß
gar nicht welcher Flughafen in der Nähe
ist und dann sehen wir uns in der
jetzigen Folge oder in der nächsten
Folge wieder und machen uns auf den Weg
zu Loch Ness Alter geil wirklich ich
kriege ein bisschen Gänsehaut sogar ich
glaube dass wir die geilste Folge von
allen da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher ich
habe richtig Bock ich war auch noch nie
ein Schottland generell so irgendwo da
in der Region ich will auch in den See
springen Leute haut rein wird geil nicht
wundern ich dachte ich starte jetzt
schon den vierten Part rein aber ich
nehme es noch mit in das Video um dann
im vierten Part mich voll und ganz auf
die vierte Reise nach Loch Ness
konzentrieren kann und damit jo Leute
was geht herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen Video ich hoffe euch geht's gut
ich befinde mich gerade auf der
Baleareninsel formentera ist neben Ibiza
und wir fahren jetzt wieder rüber und
dann geht es für mich tatsächlich einmal
nach Hause warum das erkläre ich euch
noch aber eine andere Möglichkeit gab es
nicht also schon aber dann wäre ich 20
Stunden unterwegs und das macht halt
leider absolut keinen Sinn deswegen
erstmal hier
[Musik]
mittlerweile wieder zu Hause angekommen
Leute ich habe es ja schon kurz erzählt
ich hätte 22 Stunden Reise müssen wenn
ich von Ibiza direkt nach Loch Ness
geflogen wäre deswegen bin ich jetzt
kurz nach Hause ich fliege aber
übermorgen dahin da geht's also weiter
solche verständlich sein und ich bin mal
gespannt wo die Reise dann noch so
hingeht ansonsten habe ich bis jetzt auf
jeden Fall sehr genossen ich hoffe es
hat euch gefallen das gerne nach oben
und ein Abo da haut rein Leute ciao